Now that you have completed
your professional profile,
we get to craft the headline.
Your headline appears in search
results beneath your name and photo.
With one simple title, you'll harness
the power to craft your personal brand.
When I first created a LinkedIn Presence,
I didn't realize that this
headline didn't necessarily need
to be my current job title.
Luckily, I discovered that
you can customize it.
Your headline is a great place to use
positive language to your advantage.
For example, rather than using
a phrase like seeking employment,
which might be read as unemployed,
you can use a positive phrase like
web development professional or
builder, creator, and web developer.
This is an extremely helpful way to take
control over your professional career
path and story.
Wherever you are in a job search,
you can create a headline that best
of aligns with your target jobs.